woher kommst du gerade ich komme grade
aus steglitz aus mitte nord war noch
genau ich komme gerade von der arbeit
aus berlin mitte aus einem geschäft
namens erwarte glaub ich meine arbeit
ich komme aus dem restaurant hier
daneben haben gegessen
ich komme gerade von einem freund zu
hause in von radio ich komme gerade von
der arbeit aus moabit
ich komme gerade von zu hause woher kam
die idee vom später ich komme gerade von
spanisch kurs gerade kommen wir aus
weißensee
aber ich bin eigentlich das prozent von
der arbeit
wohin gehst du ich gehe gerade hier in
den prater der ältesten bierkneipe in
berlin nach hause ich treffe mich mit
einem kollegen der sich gern boni eine
wohnung in berlin genau zu einer
freundin ja jetzt in die sonnenstraße
wir gehen zum burger laden dessen abend
jetzt gehe ich in den prater zum
fußballgucken und bier trinken
die jetzt in den prater und gucke mir
das zweite halbfinalspiel wir gehen
jetzt magischen markt und setzen uns ein
bisschen ans ufer und scheinen an die
spree und trinken erwarte keine ahnung
so schief läuft jetzt in dem rat trifft
er freunde wie kommst du denn jetzt zu
fuß und vorher mit der u-bahn in der
straßenbahn zu fuß mit der straßenbahn
und dann mit der s bahn
wir gehen dorthin also zu stehen
mit dem fahrrad
[Musik]
jetzt sucht der ist ja nicht so weit man
läuft genau noch zehn meter
wir laufen genau wir wollten eigentlich
die tram nehme jetzt laufen wir laufen
wir sind vor eine straßenbahn kommt zu
fuß
jetzt haben wir noch etwas besonderes
für euch ihr kennt dieses video material
das wir gerade gesehen habt jetzt auch
interaktiv benutzen und damit arbeiten
letzte woche haben wir euch unser neues
projekt vorgestellt und das ist eine web
app auf der ihr unsere videos auch
interaktiv sehen könnt ihr könnt eure
eigene stimme aufnehmen ihr könnt die
unter tel anklicken und dort grammatik
informationen und übersetzungen finden
probiert das mal aus mit diesem video
den link dafür findet ihr hier unten in
der beschreibung klingt mal drauf und
dann könnt ihr noch mehr deutschland
lernen abonniert auch easy german und
wir freuen uns wieder euch nächste woche
zu sehen